c'est un budget à la fois dense et
nécessairement électoraliste qui a été
présentée aujourd'hui par madame me
freeland le gouvernement trudeau annonce
l'octroi d'un chèque de 500 $ pour les
personnes de 75 ans et plus qui touchent
donc la sécurité de la vieillesse un
chèque qui sera déposé en ou le paiement
mensuel de la sécurité de la vieillesse
sera bonifié également de 10% à partir
de l'été 2022
ça veut dire 766 $ par année de plus
pour les 75 ans et plus ce sont des
bonifications de la sécurité de la
vieillesse qui font partie donc de ce
budget 2021 22 qui affiche le deuxième
plus grand déficit absolu de l'histoire
du canada 155 milliards après un déficit
de 354 milliards en 2020 21 en raison de
la pandémie
le gouvernement va investir 100
milliards sur trois ans dans la relance
économique la moitié dès cette année
ottawa va mettre en place un système de
garde d'enfants partout au pays
on partage avec les provinces 10 dollars
par jour 30 milliards sur cinq ans ça va
permettre ça à 240 milles personnes
surtout des femmes d'intégrer où de
réintégrer le marché du travail le
gouvernement prolonge aussi la
subvention salariale et la subvention
pour le loyer jusqu'au 25 septembre
mais les prestations seront réduites
tranquillement au profit d'une autre
subvention al embauche pour les
entreprises couvrant 50 % des salaires
pour une durée limitée jusqu'en novembre
prochain la pcr les prestations de
maladie de l'assurance-emploi la
location canadienne pour les
travailleurs sont bonifiés 4 dollars de
plus en taxes à payer sur les cartouches
de 200 cigarettes et une taxe sur le vha
potage à partir de 2022 et le
gouvernement va taxer les riches aussi
les voitures de luxe les bateaux de luxe
les avions privés les propriétés qui
sont laissées vacantes par des
non-canadiens une réduction est annoncé
aussi des avantages fiscaux pour les
grandes entreprises
et dernière chose il ya une nouvelle
cible pour la réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre réduction de 36%
maintenant en 2030 par rapport à 2005
grâce à 17 milliards de dollars investis
sur cinq ans dans la relance verte